翻訳: Maki Sugimoto
校正: Hiroko Kawano
あなたがお母さんに
してもらったことは何ですか？
してあげたことは何ですか？
あなたがお母さんに
迷惑かけたことは何ですか？
これが幸せになるための
内観の質問です
今まで30年間
約３千名の方々が
私共の所に心理療法の内観を
受けに参りました
健康な方々も来られますが
中には 病気や問題や悩みを抱えた方々も
多くいらっしゃいます
そういう方々は心の中に
憎しみや恨みや怒りを
抱えていることが多いようです
憎しみや怒りや恨みは
どこから来るのでしょうか？
だいたい大きく３つです
１つは「してもらっていない」
結婚記念日に旦那さんに
すっぽかされた
それから親から十分に
可愛いがられなかった
他の兄弟に比べて ですね
それから２つ目は
「してやったのにお返しがない」
してやったまでは いいのですけど
「〜のにお返しがない」と付くと
せっかく良いことをしたのに
悪因の種を作っていることになる
せっかく世話して面倒見てやったのに
お礼の一言もない
次に「迷惑かけられた」
我々は迷惑をかけながら
日々生きているわけですけれども
そういうことはすぐに忘れて
「あいつに小学校１年生の時に
トイレに閉じ込められて酷い目に遭った」
「今に見ていろ」とか
「仕事の失敗の責任を
上司が私一人に押しつけて
私はクビになってしまった」
こういう風に
「してもらってない」
「してやったのにお返しがない」
「迷惑をかけられた」
こういうことを思い出したり
数えたりすると
憎しみや恨みや怒りが
出て参ります
皆さんは誰を憎んでいますか？
誰を恨んでいますか？
誰に怒っていますか？
こういうマイナスのエネルギーは
許すことによって
手放すことが必要です
でもそれは なかなか一人ではできません
しかし心理療法の内観ですと
それが可能なのです
しかも わずか１週間という
時間でです
[過去は変えられない]
すべては受け止め方次第
活かし方次第です
過去は変えられません
しかし過去の受け止め方は
変えられます
すると未来が変わるのです
内観は受け止め方を
良い方へ変えてくれます
幸せを感じ取る力を強くします
では具体的にどうするのかといいますと
内観は非常にシンプルで
たった３つの質問だけです
１番目の質問は
「してもらったことは何ですか？」
２つ目の質問は
「してあげたことは何ですか？」
３つ目の質問は
「迷惑かけたことは何ですか？」
たったこの３つだけです
これを周りの人々に対して
一人ずつ質問していきます
お母さんとか
お母さん代わりの人とか
お父さんとか 配偶者とか
兄弟とか 友達とか 会社の人とか
一人ずつ ３つの質問をしていきます
そして時期も
区分しながらいきます
例えばお母さんですと
幼い頃 小学校時代
中学校時代 高校時代というふうに
現在までを いくつかに区切りながら
３つの質問をしていきます
これに要する時間は
たった １週間です
それだけで
大きな効果が得られます
[相手サイドから考え 自分自身で気付く]
大事なのは 視点の転換です
自分中心の見方ではなくて
相手サイドから自分自身を
客観的に見てみるわけです
そうすると 今までの
自己中心の見方ではなくて
まったく新しい過去の
事実に気づきます
今まで この出来事に関しては
私はこう思っていたけれど
お母さんの側から見ると
実はこうだったんではなかろうか？
お父さんの側から見ると
ああだったんではなかろうか？
ひょっとすると お母さんとか
お父さんの側から見た事実の方が
真実に近いのかもしれない —
こういうことに気づくと
そこから皆さんが
変わって参ります
今 私は熊本県玉名市の
蓮華院誕生寺で
内観を行っております
五重塔とか 世界一の
大梵鐘があるお寺です
どういう風に行うかといいますと
こういう風に 屏風の中に
楽な姿勢で座って
内観して頂きます
外国の方とか
足腰を痛めている方は
椅子に座って頂きます
トイレとか お茶汲みは
自由に行ってもらってかまいません
ただし他の人との会話は
禁止されています
こういう若い女性の方が
内観に来られたことがあります
この方は父親への強い
憎しみを抱いておりました
というのは お父さんの浮気と
家庭内暴力で
ご両親が中学生の時に
離婚されたのです
で どうなったのかと言いますと
高校生の時に妊娠中絶
大学生の時にヤクザと
知り合いになって
裸の写真を撮らせ
家族が慌てて高い値段で
買い戻した
そういうことがあったそうです
ある日 お母さんが
アパートに行ってみると
何か知らないけど畳の上で
爪楊枝で潰す動作をしている
「どうしたの？」って聞くと
「白い虫が うじゃうじゃ
いっぱいいるから
それを潰しているんだ」と
おかしいと思って
病院に連れて行ったら
なんと覚せい剤による
幻覚症状だったんです
急いで入院させて やっと治った
大学を卒業して 今度は
風俗産業で働きはじめた
「どうしてそういうことをしたんですか？」
と聞きましたら
「お父さんに対する仕返しだ」と
その一言でした
この方が変わったのは
内観４日目のことです
この日 彼女はお父さんに対する内観と
養育費を計算していました
すると養育費はなんと
２千万円という数字になったのです
今では３千万円かかります
あの憎いお父さん —
私と母親を苦しめた
あの憎い父親が
なんと私のために
２千万円も使ってくれていた
認めようか 認めまいか
丸一日 葛藤されていました
でも お父さんの愛情が
憎しみを溶かしていくわけです
そして最後には
「ああ やはりお父さんは
私を本当に愛してくれていたんだ」と
強く感じたわけです
最終日に「もう一度お父さんと
暮らします」と言って
明るい顔で帰って行かれました
また このような男性が
来られたことがあります
当時25歳の男性で
会社の研修で来られました
お母さんに対する
強い恨みがありました
お母さんが幼い妹と一緒に
お風呂に入っていたときに
お母さんは 髪を洗っていたんですね —
気づいたら妹の姿が見えない
湯船の底を覗き込んでみたら
沈んでいた
慌てて すくいあげて
救急車で病院に運んだけれども
もう時既に遅し
寝たきりの植物状態に
なってしまった
それからは お母さん
妹にかかりっきり
俺の面倒なんか
ちっとも見てくれない
お父さんはというと
妹のために家を改築しました
そのお金を払うために
夜も働いて
お父さんも私にかまってくれない
一番愛情の欲しかった
子どもの時に
俺はほったらかされた
だから今 人間関係も
仕事もうまくいかないんだ
お母さんが あの時
ミスさえしなかったら
お母さんが妹にかかりっきりで
俺には弁当も作ってくれなかった
おやつもなかった
最初のうちはそういうふうに
おっしゃってました
でも３日 ４日 ５日経つと
だんだん思い出してくるんです
実は お母さん
お弁当を作ってくれていた
私はそれを弁当箱に
詰めるだけだった
おやつも 買ってきてくれた
お菓子だったけど
ちゃんとあった
また 具合の悪い時でも
お母さん 毎日食事を
作ってくれたし
お掃除も洗濯もしてくれた
６日目ぐらいになりますと
もし私が同じような立場だったら
同じようなことをするだろう
こういう風に変わってまいりました
そして最終日
妹さんは中学生の頃
亡くなられたそうですけれども
亡くなった妹さんが
話しかけてきたような気がした
「お兄ちゃん 誰も悪くないんだよ
きっとこれからうまくいく」
最終日 この方もさっぱりした
明るい顔で帰って行かれました
皆さんも お母さんに
してもらったことは
沢山あると思います
今から子供時代に逆戻って
思い出してみてください
食事を作ってくださった回数は？
洗濯してくださった回数は？
お掃除の回数は？
逆に自分から進んで
お母さんにしてあげたことは
何回くらいありますか？
最後に お母さんに
迷惑や心配をかけたことは
どういうことがあったでしょうか？
兄弟喧嘩や病気や怪我
思い出してみてください
いかがでしたでしょうか？
してもらったことと 迷惑かけたことは
多かったけれど
してあげたことは
少なかったのではないでしょうか？
これが１週間の内観者の
心の変化です
最初 ３日目ぐらいまでは
懐かしい思い出を
思い出す方もいらっしゃいます
しかし今までの恨み
辛み 苦しみ 悩み
こういうことを山のように
いっぱい吐き出す方も
いらっしゃいます
そして「俺は悪くない」
「周りが悪いんだ」
「俺はむしろ被害者なんだ」
こういう風に言われる方も
いらっしゃいます
でも４日目くらいから
いろんな気付きが出て
変わって参ります
多くの人は 「してもらったことと
迷惑かけたことは多かったけれど
してあげたことが少なかったなあ」
そして相手サイドから考えると
いっぱいこんなにも迷惑をかけたんだ
「悪かったなあ」
こういう自分でも周囲の人々は
一生懸命支えてくれる —
助けてくれる
そして いろんなことを
たくさんしてくださる
私はやはり本当に
愛されていたんだなと
こういうことを強く感じると
自然と感謝の念が出て参ります
愛情の再認識
感謝の心を持てると
皆さん 立ち直って行かれる
[心の温泉]
私はよく こういうふうに譬えます
内観は「心の温泉」です
皆さんも温泉に入ると
心がほっこりすると思います
内観も心のお掃除をして
汚れを落としてリフレッシュ
させてくれる
心がほっこり暖かく
いい気分になるんですね
でも普通 人は体の方の手入れは
一生懸命します
毎日 歯を磨きますし
お風呂には入ります
病気になったら お医者さんに行きます
でも心のほうは ほったらかし
という人が多いのではないでしょうか？
皆さんの心はきれいですか？
定期的に心のお掃除はされていますか？
内観は心のクリーニングをして
リフレッシュさせてくれます
心を救うのです
心理的な病気が良くなります
人間関係も良くなります
家庭や職場の問題を解決します
幸せを感じとる力を強くする
そして多くの人々が
今までより 楽に生きられる
ようになったと言います
すべては受け止め方次第
活かし方次第です
過去は変えられません
でも過去の受け止め方は
変えられます
すると 未来が変わるんです
そしてより良い人生を送れます
ご静聴どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）